hey guys I'm just back at the last day
of a three 2017 Peter Brown is joining
me and we've got Pete Hines here from
Bethesda thank you so much for joining
us that's uh is having a bagger vu this
year you have a lot of games coming out
you have a lot of games coming out yeah
I mean one of the major I want to see
complaints but it's been a meme this
year that a lot of the games coming out
that have been shown off at e3 are
coming out next year but you guys kind
of went the other way with that we we
decided this year for our showcase we
really wanted to focus on 2017 and all
the stuff that we had going on that's
like look six months like all of the
stuff we're talking about is is gonna be
out from stuff that's coming out in two
weeks
so next month to you know by the end of
the year I worked for fallout 4
what's that worked for fallout 4 yeah it
did and you know we're big believers and
sort of not only I'm talking about
things were excited about being able to
show them yeah I tend not to like
announcing a thing but like I really
can't give you a sense of it or show you
what it's like you know we're either
able to show gameplay or in most cases
have people come by the booth and just
play like you want to play Wolfenstein
come by and and play it and try it and
see what it's like or VR or quake or
yeah or wind or whatever does the
conversation of timing start with you
like start and end with you and like are
the teams sort of responsible for that
like how do they feel oh no something
they can't show it yeah no it's a it's a
full collaborative thing between myself
you know I'm one person oh sure yeah on
a on a pretty big team that I have so
I've got folks on on my team that are
working with each of the studios on each
of the games and there's conversations
around where are these things what do we
want to talk about where do things land
and then you start to sort of set aside
the stuff that's like well that's just
not ready and that's not ready and and
part of it also is coming from from me
and and sort of figuring out kind of
from a bigger picture what we want the
story to be about and and net it out so
what you guys saw this week yeah I mean
as Peter said was flat fourth and four
shelter last year I mean is that a sort
of company-wide strategy or just
preference that you don't like to have
really long marketing late time yeah I
think it's more of a preference I mean
every game is
is going to be different in terms of
from the time you know about it to when
it comes out but I tend to prefer a
little shorter than then longer yeah but
then you know you look at some things
like elder scrolls legends which we
announced last year but that it was in
closed beta and that was open didn't
actually fully start releasing until
March and we're still putting platforms
out so it does kind of vary game to game
based on what those needs are but in
general yeah I prefer yeah shorter to
longer I mean I have identified that
which makes me I'm comforted that when
you do eventually announce the Elder
Scrolls six it'll probably be coming out
soon I won't have to wait too long I
don't I don't I don't think in general
we really want to do things any more
where it's you know you start hearing
about a two-year yeah beforehand I'm
yeah I don't know about you guys but I
just tend to find it hard to kind of
stick with and follow stuff even the
thing that I'm interested in I I prefer
to like I know about it and then I know
what I'm gonna play it as opposed to
like when is that coming out again
absolutely rip feet of info you know two
starts to sort of you know to over
saturate you know what you're trying to
think of for this game yeah yeah I mean
I'd love to talk about Vioxx I think
that's really fascinating I have had so
many conversations with people about you
know when the whole like VI in gaming
one of the most exciting things to me is
how you really get immersed and it's
like what worlds do I want to be
immersed in and a lot of them are yours
um and we knew fallout 4 was on the way
and then Skyrim came out of nowhere
when did the conversations start about
bringing Skyrim to beer um you know I
don't remember specifically but it is
this something that that both Bethesda
Game Studios and all of our studios have
been looking at in terms of like what do
we have and what do we want to do and
and in both of those cases it was that
they were that they touched on a lot of
the things that we would like to see in
a VR game right big and expansive and
kind of go and do whatever you want and
tons of content in the case of Skyrim
and fallout 4 and having sort of an
existing product allowed us to be able
to do those things without them being a
big distraction for what the studios are
ultimately working on in the case of
Bethesda Game Studios you know you
mentioned Ted 6 and everybody's asking
about it and we've said well they have
two other big titles that they'd like to
before they get around to plastics while
doing VR for these kind of experiences
allows us to do things that we think are
cool and fun without dedicating a big
chunk of team resources you can have a
much smaller group focused on this while
while the team is working on those next
big thing yeah so am i right in saying
that the entirety of both those games
labeling yeah everything that you know
and could experience and fallout 4 and
Skyrim are in the VR Wow how have you
guys like had conversations about how
people might handle like being it I mean
these are hundreds and hundreds of our
gauge yeah I mean it's not a thing that
that is already established like oh I'm
gonna stay home and play like 12 hours
of VR games non-stop yeah um but if
you're gonna try like what you could
totally do it with this and and how
folks choose to consume that try it how
much of it they spend playing a game in
VR versus in other ways really kind of
it depends on the personal preference
you know I've said before that I'm not
entirely sure that that everybody is
just gonna make this move from I do all
of my gaming on VR only and I still
think that's true but you know I have
heard from folks who say like actually
that is what I've done yeah I have
switched over to all of the stuff that I
do is on we are only so I think it
really gets down to sort of those
personal preferences and how you want to
experience gaming but if you're looking
for immersion like oh my gosh the ours
we are certainly going to provide that
on that line of thinking what can we
expect from the control options in VR I
like to say on something like vibe which
you'll be using the vibe controller sure
yeah and and the teams are still working
on a sort of which one is the default
control system and whether or not there
might be other ones that they support or
allow for for people like well I prefer
this versus that within each game that
there might be more than one but a lot
of that is still kind of in progress
testing and figuring out what you feel
what feels good and feels naturally
particularly for a game where you've got
hundreds of hours like well if you could
play it for a hundred hours it better
feel good for yeah absolutely so I would
have to imagine you have to determine if
that's even possible before you sign off
and start the project Ernest right yeah
and one of the things you can see here
that I think is cool and had been
getting feedback from folks with playing
the Skyrim is that things like dual
wielding feels very differently in VR
that when you do a wield in Skyrim on
another platform and you press a button
or two buttons that you're shooting
straight ahead it essentially one thing
yeah but the way VR works like well you
can point a hand at one thing and you
can absolutely win a hand at another you
could be swinging yeah you're watching a
cone of flame at something else so that
does offer us some more kind of
flexibility in terms of how you think
about targeting like well it's not just
the thing in the center of the screen
it's actually wherever you decide to
swing or aim that's a pretty good
incentive for someone who is really
familiar with these games already yeah
for sure Ken and and in fallout 4
you know settlements have become a
really big thing folks love kind of
building and customizing yeah how that
works how easy it is to move things
around drop things down rearrange it
again in VR is a very different more
simplified in a lot of ways yeah then
than doing it before we're kind of going
back and forth through a bunch of menus
over now I need a couch and now I need
this and you're you're going through a
lot of menus in VR it tends to be a much
more quicker tactile experience
I assume that's been just a huge process
for both teams to figure out how to take
because they're quite complicated RPGs
about how to take all the elements yeah
from a game that you have on a consoles
great it's it's the UI part right like
we don't have to figure out the quests
this time around or all of that it's the
like how is a person going to interact
if you used to press the Y or the square
button to do this like what what are you
now doing to do that in a VR game yeah
something as simple as the pip-boy like
well since it's on your arm you should
just be able to do this and your foot
boys they're like oh yeah we should just
totally do that so if you want to look
at your pip-boy you just pull your arm
up and it's mounted right there on your
on your forearm to interact with and put
it down when you're done with it yeah I
could almost imagine how you could do
that with any controller that has motion
sensing in it so even if you were
playing on a controller that you know
maybe you could do that as well
obviously not staring at your arm but
staring at the TV
it's basically under are the lessons
that being that are being learned and
redeveloping these games for VR that
might be applied to future game or
shirts I mean one thing that I've
learned in in my years at Bethesda is
that
every iteration a dev team gets on a
particular platform whether that's Xbox
or Sony or VR or whatever it is gives
them so much more information when they
go to do the next project or the next
thing because like oh we learned some
lessons about like how to take better
advantage of this or how to do that or
we had this thing we wanted to do and it
wasn't a really good fit for this game
but for the next one like we can kind of
purpose-built that from from the ground
up to take advantage of that show I
think that's not just true of us I think
all of these developers that are making
great stuff for VR as they get
experience doing it and they get that
player feedback which is so important
it's one thing to have somebody comment
on a thing that they haven't really
played or experienced when you actually
get that out into the wild players
provide feedback that's where they're
really important information comes from
to be able to address and say okay next
time around we need to do this when you
take this into account they didn't like
this but they loved this how do we
account for that how's that been on the
show floor there are reactions you're
getting playing into the way you're
developing the games right now I mean
what we're getting is a lot more of what
we've already been getting threatening
and you know we had the testing lab and
folks trying stuff but it's been really
fun to see folks getting to experience
it you know you sort of have your own
notions about what you're making but to
either see those assumptions reinforced
or potentially challenged or whatever it
is when you put it hands-on for for
press and for fans --is has been really
fun but it's been also great to see like
how much all three of them are getting
because when folks come to the booth
like we have all three of them running
in each of our roles you can just decide
like which one do you want to try and
it's been this really healthy spread of
like fallout 4 no Skyrim no doom like
everybody has their own preferences of
like the thing they want to try and some
research right there yeah and see like
it hasn't been like oh it's 90% Skyrim
or 90% fallout it's been pretty evenly
split across across all three yeah um
personally I think it's just really
exciting like I mean obviously there are
a lot of indie devs who are very
passionate about via getting into it
building those experience but you know
to see a company as big as you guys
getting so solidly behind VR is I think
something not everybody would have
expected but is really fantastic I mean
do you personally see the
being like quite a concrete future in in
what gaming is going to become yeah but
I don't think it's going to be the kind
of thing that we've seen in the past and
I think we're seeing a little bit of a
reaction to that now this is just my
personal opinion but I think in the past
when you see like a Microsoft or a sony
says here's our next big platform you've
been playing on the ps3 here's the ps4
the adoption rate to those things looks
like this right it goes straight up like
you go from zero people to tens of
millions of people almost overnight in
the case of VR you're not seeing that
same kind of spike it's going to be a
slow gradual thing that people continue
to do and Sony's now continue to grow
their audience that Microsoft has talked
about maybe some of the stuff that
they're going to do with their new
console starting next year but it's
going to continue to grow on the PC on
all these other platforms at a more
gradual rate but it's still something
that we think ultimately is going to be
important and is going to be fun and
something that people are going to want
to yeah I haven't played and we want to
provide you know the kinds of
experiences that we enjoy oh yeah I mean
as Peter said like this stuff just
hasn't been done like that it's
impossible to like do this kind of
research so to actually put these games
out there see how people deal with them
see how they respond how long do people
want to be in via house a motion
sickness playing out like on a grand
scale
like how is everyone dealing with it I
feel like this is going to be really
important for sure and it's a great
opportunity for us because they're I
mean truthfully there's no universe in
which we would start from scratch and
build a VR only version of say a fallout
4 yeah I mean it's just massive and it
doesn't make sense but if you can take
something that exists and and bring it
out and provide a really good experience
on that platform and see what it's like
it doesn't form and and help you learn
an awful lot so that down the road
you're incorporating that into what
you're doing and you know as I said it's
something all of our Studios are looking
at we don't really do like mandates like
that you have to have a mobile game you
have to do a VR title but it's more
making the tools and the info available
letting have those conversations with
the platform holders to figure out what
if anything they want to do or what
makes sense for what they're working on
I think you're seeing the first few
things and we're going to continue to
explore it and develop more games for it
as we go forward
well I'd love to go back to the General
Conference for a second what were you
most excited about getting to debut or
show off at the ER well the thing I was
most excited about was the part where
was over because it's really stressful
and nervous but together so the part
where was done and I didn't massively
screw up was good uh you know I think we
were we were really excited about wolf
and IVA with them because those guys
have been you know working for years and
years on those things under wrap and you
know if you've ever developed the video
game and not been able to answer the
question of like so what are you working
on for literally years at a time like
yeah it's it's restricting it's
confining and so to finally be able to
put those things out and see people
react to them so positively was was a
lot of fun but honestly the other thing
for me was just like in addition to
talking about things that were just this
year was the pace of it I was a big
thing for me is I really wanted it to
kind of move along you know we've done
different things
Todd obviously two years ago did a
really full intensive thing for Fallout
4 we've done longer things for some
games like Dishonored 2 we've done
shorter things and this year we just
felt like because we had so much
hands-on we really wanted to move along
and sort of have it at a pace where you
understand what's going on
but then we're able to you know to show
more of the game as we go along you can
come by and play it that was that was
kind of the biggest thing for me is to
execute on that idea I'm certainly not
buttering you up by sort of God you guys
have maybe the strongest line-up out of
any publisher out there adding this
thing I mean is that pretty much
apparent to you guys / absolutely not no
I really look look this is what I do for
a living I walk very much we're eight a
paranoia is anybody care about what
we're doing is anybody gonna buy this
but if you could attribute what I'm in
describing anyway we had the way I see
and I think a lot of people do see it as
Bethesda just being a very strong and
consistent publisher what would you
attribute that to me it's hard for me to
it's the only place I've ever worked
inside the industry so you're the common
denominator I not me at all
it might in fact be in spite of me I I
think it probably comes if you look back
at our roots and kind of where Bethesda
started 30 years ago now
professor was a small mom-and-pop
developer that just happened to publish
their own stuff just for PC and when I
got there in 99 it was just the starting
point at which Cinemax had required it
acquired Bethesda and was starting the
process of like you guys think too small
you need to think bigger you know we
needed to kind of grow and not grow like
we're not trying to be movie EA
Activision you know relatively speaking
we have 1500 odd people around the world
we don't have 10,000 12,000 to 20,000
people but we like to make games that
kind of resonate with us the kinds of
things that we want to play we're going
to focus on a small number of them now
this year kind of feels like we have an
awful lot going on relatively speaking
but you know we don't do 12 big releases
a year we tend to focus on a smaller
number of things and try and execute
those to a high level and then take
those learnings and and take them to the
next thing so that's how we ended up
working with Studios like arcane and
it'd write those conversations started
not with like hey we want to acquire you
but it was we want to work with you guys
and we think what you do is cool and
they eventually evolved into
conversations of well maybe it makes
more sense for you guys to just join us
or maybe it makes more sense for us to
join you but it didn't start off that
way it started off with we like the kind
of stuff that you make the kind of stuff
that we enjoy playing and it shares a
DNA with us so that you know a game like
evil within it's not necessarily
something you'd associate with Bethesda
yeah not like we're a household name in
survival horror and have been for 30
years but but Shinji and his team at
tango shares some common ideas in terms
of immersiveness or kind of taking where
survival horror was headed and taking it
back almost to the roots when shinji
started that genre of no no it's
supposed to be about scarcity of
resources and keeping the player off
balance and sort of struggling to
survive as opposed do I have lots of
guns and ammo and I'm just going to mow
my way through a problem that you know
those kinds of ideals resonate well with
us and you know we hope every time we do
something it's always a hope of I hope
people like this I hope people we like
to think we know what we're doing but I
don't think we
I don't think we walk around with a lot
of hubris to say no everybody's gonna
love this I mean Skyrim like I remember
thinking like I really love this but I
hope everybody else does too and we
launched that game like we didn't know
like how well is this going to go over
like we think it's really great but ya
know talking about putting in the hands
of consumers like even if you let
everybody in the booth play it it's very
different than letting anybody in the
world play it and seeing what they think
so we always you know we try and sort of
come from a place of strength and
confidence and and do what we think we
we do well I mean you guys have such a
dedicated fanbase like I know a lot of
people in this room just bloody love
Bethesda and I'm not sure every
publisher can really say that I mean
does that evoke a sense of sort of like
comfort for the teams like it's no
there's no comfort like its success is
great and having people like you is is
wonderful but I mean let's be honest
like this is an industry of what have
you done for me lately and then you
certainly get a mountain of credit for
things you've done in the past but
there's always that sense of but what's
the next one going to be and how good is
the next thing you're going to do you're
judged on the next thing that you're
gonna you're going to do and so we try
as best we can to you know sort of live
up to those expectations and stay very
humble in our approach knowing that like
we don't just get to like stumble and
roll out a piece of garbage that
everybody's going to hate and then we
just get forgiven like we have to
continue to deliver we have to continue
to to push ourselves and and be the kind
of developer and publisher that people
expect us to be or that tide is going to
change real quick I mean it's crazy that
any game is ever finished and shipped
let alone ones that are consistently
impressive yeah sure yeah yeah I mean I
know like this is just us being greedy
at this point because you are giving us
so many titles this year but are you
able to speak to anything that's past
2017 uh there's some really cool stuff
coming down the road that I've yeah that
I've gotten to play that I've gotten to
but yeah we're not yeah ready yet about
down the road aside from that I just see
Elvis works a scroll six is coming right
like it'll it'll come Scrolls
we'll eventually be made there's
multiple big releases down the the plan
for those folks they they felt like they
wanted to work on some other stuff and
do some other things and quite honestly
like they didn't want to be a developer
that was just Elder Scrolls fallout
Elder Scrolls fallout for the rest of
their development careers and you've got
a lot of people in that studio who have
been there a very long time and they
wanted to be able to sort of self
determine what things they worked on
next whether it was existing stuff
whether it was new IP and I think God
and his team have earned the right given
the quality of this stuff to be able to
say look we know that everybody really
wants Elder Scrolls 6 but we as creative
people want to be able to do stuff that
we're really passionate about and I
think once you see sort of how the next
two titles come out and then how Elder
Scrolls six kind of ties into what those
games are doing and about I think it all
makes sense but I think it's going to be
hopeful I'm going to be a while before
all of those things happen but just that
leads me to another question though yeah
is there any credence to the the concept
that Elder Scrolls and fallout are
somehow a part of one timeline very far
apart I haven't the foggiest notion how
anybody could make the look that they
are well we made Elder Scrolls and a
completely different developer and
publisher came up with fallout yeah
which we then acquired so how did they
do I mean these things can be decided
after the fact they don't have to
originally no I don't think there's any
universe in which those universes are in
the same unit so I'm not I didn't come
up with that oh no I know you did I've
seen that and right most of the time I
just looked at look at those questions
very quizzically I don't understand how
you made but I don't know whether those
people don't understand like no fallout
1 fallout 2 were made by right other
people and we acquired it made the third
one but the first two and what those
games are about in the universe they set
up we adopted we did most people just
think about when they think of fallout
now they they really just identify with
3 & 4 so I think you're not in the
modern era I mean right fine that's
where their head is set at but I just
wanted to make sure I could old guys
like me and developers one coming out
and we remember wasteland explore that
way and that's what yeah no that's not a
thing that's good for everybody
something that is a thing I would love
to talk about is a creation Club you
spoke about a little bit this uh there's
been some kind of ruminating from people
online you know but what exactly is it
is it is it a paid mods 2.0 some people
are worried about I mean what can you
tell us about that in the credit system
so creation Club was a was a new thing
that this the team came up with to say
we want to continue to make and do stuff
for Skyrim and fallout 4 and we want to
create an ecosystem that works across
both games but we want to leave mods the
way that they are and we don't want to
change how that works and we want to
actually be able to not only do some of
this ourselves but to also bring in
external developers or even bring in
people who are known for making mods but
not bring them in as modders like bring
them in as now you're a game developer
like you're working with us not on a mod
you know whatever we greenlight that you
make has to meet certain criteria it
can't be something that you've already
created that you say well now I want to
take this and offer through creation
club because that's not what creation
club is about but it's almost like
they're almost like mini DLCs in some
way although that's probably not even a
great point of reference but they are
internally created or internally created
along with external developers they're
fully internally developed and worked
the same across all three platforms
they're guaranteed to work with your
save games they don't turn off
achievements or trophies unlike mods
they're guaranteed to work with all DLC
they'll be localized as needed they will
be put out and created as official
content from the studio but just like
there's art in our games that people
outside the game studio make like we
need a bunch of flower pots like we
don't just make flower pots all day and
like they focus on the bigger stuff and
outsource flower pots to somebody else
to make this is in some ways a lot like
that it's all official content and we
don't have any issues with platforms
like what kind of things are you or are
you not allowed to include and what you
do because it's coming from us it's Qaid
by us it's managed by us as official
content and then put
and made available and and you get to
clarify pricing on that one it's not
yeah it's not meant to be I mean
ultimately we'll see the stuff that
comes up with but it's not meant to be
like high price point stuff it's
supposed to be small little things that
you can add to your game the price
points will vary well we want to figure
that out as we go along honestly it's
all dependent on what the folks who want
to who are working on this want to
create like it's a pitch like okay I
want to make this thing I want to make
that thing and and then it gets approved
and they start working on it and and
again like if they're a modder that's
been accepted they're no longer a mater
they're now a game developer as soon as
they get greenlit like they're getting
paid like any other developer that works
on our that works on our stuff right
well that's awesome
I mean thank you so much for sharing all
of that with us I wish we had like
another half hour to talk because we
definitely could yeah I mean it's great
to see everything that's coming this
year I mean I know everyone's excited to
have some massive games to play I will
sit tight for Elder Scrolls six I can
handle that because you'll definitely be
bringing more great game we will come up
with names between now and then better I
feel like you could probably handle that
for me right that's alright but uh thank
you so much for taking the time to come
and talk thank you guys for having me on
thanks Peter and we will be back shortly